après l' agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament qui suit ainsi d'ailleurs les
recommandations qui ont été formulés
hier soir par l' agence européenne du
médicament
il n'y a pas lieu de suspendre la
vaccination par astrazeneca sur ce
vaccin astrazeneca à ceux à ce stade et
il faut avoir confiance dans ce vaccin
et se faire vacciner sur la
recommandation du ministre solidarité de
la santé en lien avec les autorités
sanitaires françaises
la décision qui a été prise c'est de
suspendre par précaution la vaccination
avec astrazeneca en espérant la
reprendre vite si la vie de l'om a le
permis
[Musique]
du
key
et
[Musique]